one of the things about this example is
that even though it's so much longer
that actually makes it better for
practicing with synthetic division
because it gives you more opportunities
to go through that step that you have to
repeat and repeat and repeat
and it gets into your head a little bit
better okay so let's begin
the first thing you do is uh you write
that that upside down
division sign yeah and it's going to be
a pretty long one
because we've got a lot of numbers to
fit right okay
now there's a number that goes up here
what is it
in this case it's two right
the way you'd say it is where does it
actually come from it's the
solution to if we made this an equation
right x minus two equals zero
right alternatively by the way this is a
um
just as a bit of notation that i sort of
left off from wednesday
but you can say that this right this is
a polynomial equation right you can say
it has
solutions it's one solution or you can
say it has roots
right because it's an equation you could
graph it right however
if i went from an equation to an
expression
does anyone know the difference between
an equation the expression is
yeah so an equation equation has an
equals sign right an expression it's
just the x minus two
on its own it's not equal to anything
okay now since it's not equal to
anything you can't solve it
does that make sense um and in the same
way because it's not equal to anything
you can't draw it
right so it can't have roots right
however this number of
two right is just as important to this
expression as it is to this equation
okay
so it's still meaningful we can't call
it a solution or a root so
you may remember this from year nine
it's called a zero
right because if you put two into there
it makes that polynomial equal to
zero right and sometimes there are
multiple ones all right
so two we've written down the zero now
let's follow on and write down
all our coefficients okay so we go
two minus four
zero watch out read carefully
minus five two three
minus one okay
remember these correspond to how many
x's sixes how many x's are the fives how
many x's are fours answer there are none
right please include that and so on
all right now what i do next is draw
another line underneath
and my first step in my actual working
out of the
and by the way if you if you haven't
gone and looked it up
it is the quotient that you end up with
okay um what do i do
okay i just take the leading coefficient
you just jump down
yeah okay now what i do with that
multiply and here's the here's where it
starts to cycle yeah
multiply add yep okay
multiply out
multiply add
multiply add
yes so far so good
multiply add
multiply
okay any problems with arithmetic does
it check out
i think it looks okay it looks okay all
right now now that i've got my
coefficients right i wanna
map that to the fact that this was
degree six right degree six
and i was dividing by degree one okay so
therefore my question should be degree
five okay likewise if i was dividing
degree 6 by degree
3 what i'd end up with is degree 3 right
and so on
okay so this 4 therefore this has um
an x to the 5 attached to it that's the
x to the 4
that's the x to the 3. this is going to
be an x squared
right minus 8x there's the constant and
there's
the remainder okay
all right now let's write this as the
division transformation right
i'm going to take this guy right and i'm
just going to do um i'm going to call
him
p for polynomial okay
i can say therefore this polynomial is
equal to
the divisor by the quotient
fine
okay divisor quotient and then you add
your remainder on the end which just
corrects and make it all make sense okay